you
on the 16th of November operation
Attleboro is in full swing here a tiny
airstrip combat veterans of the 1st
Infantry Division begin boarding assault
helicopters to move into the battle in
the forward area word has been received
that contact has been made with the
Vietcong these units are quickly
deployed to reinforce other elements of
the big red one already in battle at
another location in Tainan province more
troops of the 1st Infantry are hitting
ABC headquarters under pressure the
enemy deserts his camp and the tough US
troopers overrun the base destroying it
as they go start piles of enemy food
such as these crocks of smoked fish are
discovered and destroyed stores of salt
are also located biggest find of all
however is 1,250 tons of rice it is the
largest enemy rice cache taken during
operation Attleboro demolition men set
charges in the pile as the rice is
ordered destroyed the rice along with
everything else in the suspected enemy
distribution center is put to the torch
the smoke from the conflagration can be
seen from the air many kilometers away
on the 18th of November gunships of the
1st Infantry Division leave tiny narrow
strip seeking enemy main force units in
war zone see they are going to wreck
annoyed her by fire throughout tiny
province 96 kilometers northwest of
Saigon operation Attleboro has been
going on for more than a month from the
air as well as in the jungles below the
enemy is difficult to pinpoint these
missions hope to locate shifting enemy
all roads and rivers are closely
observed for any sign of Viet Cong
traffic jungles bordering these
thoroughfares screen much of them from
view an artillery spotting aircraft
darts by below calling in howitzer fire
on a suspected VC position a puff of
purple smoke marks the target and the
gunship laces the area with machine-gun
fire friendly shells whistle by on their
way to the target and it's time to get
out at thou Aang 24 kilometres east of
Tainan a group of engineers is lined up
on a recently completed bridge it is 21
November and these men are about to be
decorated for heroic deeds performed
during operation Attleboro the Silver
Star for gallantry in action is
presented by Major General William II de
PUE commanding general of the 1st
Infantry Division also the Army
Commendation Medal for meritorious
achievement
the red satin pillow with its proud
burden moves down the long line keeping
pace with a general each individual
receiving the symbol of the Army's
recognition with dignity and justifiable
pride in a job well done in the vicinity
of black virgin mountain northwest of
Tainan an army o1 bird dog spots enemy
positions with marker rockets pointing
out the foe for attacking US Air Force
jets things get hot for the communist
forces as napalm rains down from the
Jets hissing by overhead by the third
week of November tactical air support
for American ground forces engaged in
operation Attleboro is being provided at
the rate of 50 or more air strikes per
day on the fringe of the strike path the
Army's spotter plane observes the effect
of the jet attacks then when the aerial
assault has ended artillery units take
over to deliver the final portion of the
one-two punch at Dow Ching headquarters
of the 1st Infantry Division during
operation Attleboro the airstrip is in
constant use as planes shuttle in and
out of its 2300 foot runway see 123 's
of the US Air Force bring in troop
reinforcements and all kinds of supplies
one moment it's drums of fuel being
unloaded then it's boxes of ammunition
by 23 November 300,000 pounds of cargo
another assignment given to the Air
Force is the large-scale evacuation of
Vietnamese civilians from the war zone
gathered from critical areas by our
infantry these people are transported to
safer localities
the amount of activity at daocheng
airfield is almost unbelievable as
operation Attleboro begins reaching its
peak between army helicopter troop lifts
missions the Air Force uses the
unimproved strip the runway here is only
30 feet wide throughout the western and
northern portion of Tainan province
combined us ground forces from three
divisions and two brigades are uprooting
communists main force units from
long-held position by 23 November 1004
zuv enemy equipment and supplies
including 2,500 tons of rice have been
captured again and again during
operation Attleboro forward air
controllers call upon Air Force jets to
soften up pockets of enemy resistance
response from tactical air support units
is almost instantaneous enemy targets
are hard hit as forward air controllers
direct the strikes in these official US
Air Force films North Vietnamese Regular
Army units are under attack entrenched
in a complex of fortified bunkers the
enemy launched a mortar attack against
elements of the 1st Infantry Division
to dislodge the enemy main force units
from their position napalm and
high-explosive are used against them
forward air control pinpoints the
targets during operation Attleboro more
than 200,000 tons of bombs and napalm
are dropped on the enemy as the US Air
Force provides 24-hour support for
American ground forces engaged in
driving the enemy out of plane en
Provence
during the period 21 through 24 November
elements of the 25th Infantry Division
push into the jungles of contemn
province during Operation Paul Revere
for the mission of this unit is to
locate enemy positions which have been
bombed out by our b-52s and evaluate the
damage for the troopers it's rugged
going as they penetrate the wilderness
the undergrowth is so thick in this area
it obscures enemy booby traps planted
along the way one of the troopers is
impaled through the ankle with a
concealed punch I stay
following this unfortunate incident the
troopers are doubly alert as they push
on toward their objective at the site
where the b-52s had struck a landing
zone is established and additional
troops fly in the location is
approximately 56 kilometres northwest of
Pleiku in this locality the men of the
25th find 90 demolished bunkers and the
bodies of 66 North Vietnamese Army
regulars from all appearances the b-52
strikes were effective in neutralizing
these enemy positions for three days the
Tropic lightning infantrymen sweep the
area west of ledgering
but no contact is made finally they
return to their forward base camp at
pleasure rang
as the mission ends dry clothing is the
first thought of the returnees mail from
home is next at their mud clog command
post near like a elements of the 11th
Armored Cavalry prepare for a Road
clearing action along Highway 13 in
support of operation Attleboro all
vehicles taking part in the armored
convoy are given a final check and many
are loaded with sandbags these are used
to help reduce damage from exploding
mines a last-minute briefing is held on
possible danger points along the route
then it's time to move out made up of
tanks self-propelled 105 millimeter
howitzers and armored assault vehicles
the convoys mission is to keep the road
to unlock 50 kilometers to the north
free of Vietcong activity along the way
the battered wrecks of APCs destroyed in
previous battles remind the men to
proceed with caution parts of the
highway are in bad shape and the convoy
slows down the road is strategically
located near the eastern border of
Tainan province and despite its
condition is vital to supply and
communications in the area in late
afternoon the convoy arrives without
incident at their unlocked command post
first order of business is setting up
camp and establishing a defense
perimeter for the night
aiming circles are set to position the
battery of howitzers for night firing
harassment of the VC next morning 15
November the men of the 11th get ready
to do it all over again in addition to
keeping the highway open the convoy is
also acting as a blocking force to
prevent the escape of fleeing Viet Cong
as operation Attleboro sweeps across
tiny in province
the road winds through a heavily wooded
area and the men remain on alert for
signs of a possible ambush at key points
along the route
the convoy halts for fire emissions
once again aiming circles are set and
the self-propelled howitzers are brought
into position to pound suspected VC
positions along the road ahead
mission completed the convoy moves ahead
toward like a throughout the operation
the 11th armored encounters only
sporadic sniper fire and the vital
highway is kept open
spearheaded by three of the Navy's new
patrol air-cushion vehicles a series of
joint Navy Special Forces operations are
wreaking havoc among the VC in the
Mekong Delta
these strange-looking craft can travel
over both land and water at speeds up to
60 miles an hour a twin caliber 50
machine gun highlights the vehicles
armament in addition it carries its own
radar to m60 machine guns and a
complement of troops driven forward by
an airplane type motor the crafts move
out from base camp on the first leg of a
typical one-day mission in the area of
Makua sixty kilometers southwest of
Saigon this is a low lying farm region
but the unusually heavy rains have
caused floods which have not yet receded
first stop is an isolated Special Forces
camp where the fact these must pick up a
number of CI DG troops familiar with the
terrain meanwhile at base camp several
armed helicopters are being readied to
support the pack these surface
operations in addition to caliber 7.62
machine guns these Huey's also carry a
full complement of 2.75 rockets armed
and fueled the choppers join the mission
leaving the Special Forces camp the pack
these fan out to begin the sweep the
floods in the area have created
hardships for the VC by inundating his
caches and hiding places and making it
harder for him to move the choppers join
in above staying in constant
communication as they search the vast
flooded area for any sign of suspicious
activity a group of dugouts is sighted
and a pack these speeds toward the spot
the boats are quickly brought alongside
and the occupants question
they are local farmers and nothing
suspicious is found after their dugouts
and belongings have been thoroughly
searched they are allowed to proceed the
pack these move on across the trackless
marshlands also supporting the sweep are
several air cats small fiberglass
airboats mounted with a caliber 30
machine gun finally DC contact is made
as one of the pack these is hit by
sniper fire from an isolated hut the
crafts twin 50s immediately go into
action smothering the hut with a hail of
bullets
riflemen open up on VC spotted hiding
underwater and breathing through reeds
an armed Huey in the area makes a pass
at the target adding its 2.75 rockets to
the barrage just to make sure a gunner
in the chopper pours in some fire of his
own as the hut and nearby bunker are a
hard hit
when it's all over troops from the pack
V cautiously searched the remains
several VC bodies are found but
miraculously one man has survived the
onslaught taken aboard
he seems dazed as he receives medical
treatment for his wounds the sweep moves
on
not far away several camouflaged VC
dugouts are discovered they yield some
rice ammunition and a number of
documents wrapped in waterproof covering
at a pre-arranged rendezvous point the
pack these come together prisoners
including the one blood-spattered VC who
survived the attack are carefully
gathered together for transfer to a
chopper the Huey arrives and while
hovering just above water level loads
the prisoners for return to base camp
continuing the operation the pack these
draw fire from a tree covered island
they moved through the area raking the
undergrowth with bullets in an attempt
to flush the VC
the sniping subsides and troops wearing
armored vests wade into the marsh two
more VC are spotted hiding under water
and one is killed trying to escape the
other is captured and brought aboard
with the our growing late the men call
it a day and head for home during the
return trip they remain constantly on
alert as hundreds of empty shells tell
the story of the day's action reaching
base camp the vehicles are brought
ashore and their weary crews finally
relax VC prisoners are assembled for
preliminary questioning to be followed
by airlift to the rear another Navy
Special Forces operation concludes
successfully with a few bullet holes the
only enemy score Atsui de a vietnamese
force under special forces command lands
for a well-deserved rest when the area
is suddenly raked by sniper fire cut by
surprise the men scramble for cover as
the air strips defensive force
immediately goes into action hit and
pinned down by the heavy fire the
wounded await medical attention armoured
personnel carriers quickly move out for
a counter-attack but the snipers have
faded back into the jungle meanwhile the
men wounded in the attack are
immediately evacuated by air ambulance
to tiny airstrip five kilometers away
awaiting transport to the hospital the
beleaguered troops wonder how long it
will be before they are back in action
near Tainan is the site of a Special
Forces training camp the heavily
fortified installation serves as the
main facility for training civilian
defense irregular forces in the area the
course in combat tactics is taught by
Vietnamese classroom instruction is kept
to a minimum with the heavy emphasis on
field exercises looking like walking
trees the camouflage troops cautiously
sweep toward a simulated DC position a
smoke grenade signals VC contact and
under the watchful eye of an instructor
a concentrated attack is launched five
days later it's the real thing
as the camp is used as a base for
operation renegade Vietnamese CID G
troops under the supervision of the 5th
Special Forces are flown to an LZ 35
kilometers southeast of Tainan where
Vietcong anti-aircraft positions are
suspected - air strikes have softened up
the area however and the sweet finds it
largely deserted with the VC positions
abandoned
twelve small US Navy minesweepers have
the responsibility of keeping the Saigon
River and main harbor clear of Vietcong
mine a great volume of critical war
material flows through Saigon daily any
delay could hamper our efforts
the Vietcong well aware of this have
made many attempts to mine the river and
main harbour minesweeping is a dangerous
job the riverbanks offer the constant
threat of Viet Cong attack to protect
themselves from such attacks these boats
are armed with both heavy and light
machine guns men and weapons stand ready
against sudden attack on this day 28
November enemy small-arms fire strikes
the water around the ship our men answer
with grenade launchers and machine guns
raking the shore with a concentrated
barrage for seven minutes
US army helicopters may be called in the
event of attack during the skirmish
4,000 rounds of ammunition were fired
the boats continued on patrol
in special ceremonies at fool oy vietnam
held the morning of 24 november from
your knowin cokie presents awards to
officers of the 1st Infantry Division
including Major General William II deep
you the 1st infantry division commander
and Brigadier General James F
Hollingsworth junior assistant division
commander also honored is Brigadier
General John our Dean assistant division
commander general Westmoreland and two
Vietnamese generals watch the ceremony
other division officers receive the
Republic of Vietnam national order fifth
class they are congratulated by general
Westmoreland the awards the US Silver
Star for valor to three Vietnamese
officers and an enlisted man Vietnamese
awards for gallantry are given to a
number of US and listed men for days
later
premier key arrives at pleiku airbase
where he is greeted by boys from the
military academy at pleiku premier key
is proceeding by helicopter to play doh
chi an advance camp of the 4th division
where he will give awards
later the premiere returns to play cool
with Major General Arthur s Collins jr.
who was awarded the Vietnamese gallantry
cross with palms generals Larsen Collins
and Lee did him goodbye and the premiere
begins his return flight on 16 November
villagers of Simon near Cam Ranh Bay
gather for a periodic visit by an
assistant medic from 5th Special Forces
mothers children and old folks make up
the bulk of those seeking medical aid
the village chief announces sick call
and the patient's line up for treatment
by Sergeant John piernas in an old villa
the sergeant is capably assisted by his
Vietnamese nurse who helps to keep order
among the hundred villagers seeking aid
for headaches rashes or other minor
ailments after sick call the medics
distribute candy to the eager youngsters
by giving us much help as we can to the
beleaguered people of Vietnam we hope to
make more friends just one more way to
win the war in the heavily populated
refugee packed city of Saigon seen here
in late November the handling of refuse
is a major problem tons of it are
created daily it is brought to central
points by primitive methods such as this
hand drawn cart then manually loaded
onto old trucks even at the dump
slow hand labour removes the refuse the
US Army has now introduced unloading by
power equipment Sergeant Glenn F
McCullough a Special Forces soldier now
advises the Sanitation Department
sergeant McCullough the sole US adviser
to this 1,500 man operation was asked 30
McCullough how do you get the Vietnamese
people to use the new ideas and
use the new tools you have here well
sometimes it's a little bit difficult
first of all you've got to demonstrate
the use of the tool to them show them
how to use it teach them how to use it
and then show them that it's better than
maybe the antique they've been been
using and once you've got them convinced
then it's no problem they go right for
it could you give us an example of this
all right one thing is they an electric
metal cutter these fellows have been
used to cutting all their sheet metal
and everything with a chisel and a
hammer
this kind of antiquey method so I went
down to the p80 warehouse we've got an
electric metal shears and it took about
two and a half days of intensive showing
and teaching and then finally they got
to the point and now they use it every
day
I'd like it real well and once you show
them how easy it is and how much better
it is use the electricity no problem
after the sergeant trains mechanics
oversees maintenance and supervises
conversion of equipment such as flatbeds
to dump trucks before sergeant
McCullough arrived about 400 tons of
refuse were collected each month with
his modern methods and new power
equipment from the US the department now
averages 1,500 tons a month
the infantry school at Fort Benning is
host to sergeant major of the army
William o Wooldridge
on 15 November the sergeant major calls
on Major General Robert H York
commanding general of Fort Benning he
also makes a courtesy call to Brigadier
General Charles M mount junior
commanding general of the Army training
center the Army's number one enlisted
man who recently returned from Vietnam
then joins trainees in the field where
he observes a class in bayonet drill he
also sees the men being trained for
hand-to-hand combat then it's on to the
firing range where trainees squeeze them
off the sergeant major who received much
of his training at Fort Benning joins
the troops for lunch and some informal
talk I could sit here for an hour and
just tell you how much the training
program has improved in the army since
I've been in it then and you get
absolutely the best training that the
Army's ever given today and and of
course this this makes you the best
soldiers the Army's ever turned out
there's no question about it we're we're
real proud of you and we love to see you
finish your training to come out to the
regular units and they're all delighted
to have you because they know that
you're a good soldier when you get there
and you're well trained and you're well
motivated and we just welcome you to the
team and we're real proud of you and
real glad to have you I'm going over to
Vietnam again in December I want to
visit and it's always just great to see
the guys over there and talk with them
and they're doing a fine job get along
fine as a matter of fact they have less
problems in Vietnam we do anywhere else
in the army and I guess it just proves
the old saying that a busy soldier
doesn't have time for problems and
they're pretty busy over there I enjoyed
having lunch here with you it's real
good and I'm very happy to see that we
haven't changed one thing in the army
we've still got plenty of carrots
the next day sergeant major Wooldridge
stops in at Martin Army Hospital where
he visits with soldiers who were wounded
in Vietnam
who you with once they bury their ball
once every third well you know we have
sort of second cousins you know with
it's a fine outfit uh-huh
you know your old boss has just been
promoted to a major-general and he's
going down to command the training
center at Fort Polk Louisiana general
Williamson I saw that in the army times
and also a local paper or even promoted
in one day well I guess the 173rd is
still running all over the third Arlen
co-heir aren't fighting all over the
place like they're always doing you get
along all right then yeah there are
things we have been taking good care of
everything good
plenty of food right give you seconds
here if you wanted yes not all you need
no problem no problem
I see right nice man
you